the basic necessities of being a woman  like cooking shocking to me yeah it's a  privilege like you you have something in  your holster in your bag that you can  whip out whenever you need to for a man  like okay I can cook for him I can clean  for him because you have it on you a lot  of women have to learn that on their on  their own or just had to go throughout  life and learning it they they never  retaught it or they never needed to have  it until they were in a position where  like oh I I can't do this on my own I  can't cook I can't clean I can't work a  simple vacuum I can't do this because  things have been done for me my whole  life where I was never taught that and  so you shouldn't look at it as it like  oh I was taught this from jump I was  taught how to cater to my man or be a  woman you should take them